sehr geehrte Damen und Herren herzlich
willkommen zur Wahl Nachlese mit unserer
Spitzenkandidatin Christin Brinker und
unserem Bundessprecher Tino kuballa Frau
Weidel lässt sich entschuldigen sie ist
krank nach den Statements der beiden
haben sie Möglichkeiten Fragen zu
stellen Frau Brinker bitte ja schönen
guten Morgen auch von meiner Seite
lassen Sie mich zuerst sagen dass wir
als
afd-hauptstadtpartei sehr stolz sind
dass wir zugewonnen haben gestern und ja
hier unser
wlan-potenzial gut wieder aktivieren
konnten wir wissen alles waren sehr
kurzer und ein sehr harter kalter
Wahlkampf der Wahlkampf auf den Straßen
war sehr anstrengend aber wir haben auch
auf der Straße einen deutlichen Zuspruch
gewinnen festgestellt egal in welchem
Bezirken wir unterwegs waren ich bin ja
persönlich auch durch die Bezirke
gegangen und habe mit vielen Wählern aus
unterschiedlichsten Schichten sprechen
können und
war positiv überrascht also da gibt es
tatsächlich eine Entwicklung ja hin zu
uns zur AFD das hat sich ja auch im
Wahlergebnis abgezeichnet und wir sind
besonders froh dass wir jetzt ja vier
Abgeordnete mehr wahrscheinlich im
Abgeordnetenhaus haben werden also von
13 auf 17 Abgeordnete vergrößert sich
die Fraktion dass es wichtig für uns wir
werden mit Sicherheit als ja sehr starke
Opposition weiterarbeiten so wie wir das
im Vorfeld schon getan haben seit 2016
und je mehr Abgeordnete dabei sind es
ist natürlich umso besser
ansonsten muss man tatsächlich
feststellen wir haben eine kurze
Auswertung ja mal gemacht und ich habe
mir angeschaut
wie sich tatsächlich das Wahlergebnis
zusammensetzt positiv ist dass wir mehr
Frauen gewinnen konnten für uns und was
bei einer ersten Sichtung auch
festzustellen ist dass wir auf jeden
Fall großen Zuspruch unter den Arbeitern
und Angestellten
haben dass es unser Wähler Klientel also
diejenigen die auch den Staat mit ihren
Steuereinnahmen tragen und stützen genau
die fühlen sich durch uns angesprochen
von uns vertreten das ist auch ein sehr
wichtiger Punkt für uns und wir haben
auch festgestellt bei einer ersten
Kurzanalyse dass die Kernthemen mit
denen sind wir nach wie vor der Chor und
das kommt bei unseren Wählern auch an
Kernthemen heißt
Kriminalitätsbekämpfung ist für viele
unserer Wähler das Hauptthema und
natürlich auch soziale Gerechtigkeit und
Inflationsbekämpfung das waren Dinge die
wir auch immer wieder angesprochen haben
und die offensichtlich beim Wähler auch
verfangen haben
wir haben bei erster Analyse kaum Wähler
an die CDU verloren die CDU hat
maßgeblich gewonnen durch Wähler der SPD
und auch der FDP die gewandert sind das
zeigt und verdeutlicht dass wir ja uns
in Berlin mit unserer Wählerschaft
konsolidiert haben und wir davon
ausgehen wenn wir unsere Themen weiter
so ansprechen dass wir diese
Wählerschaft auch noch wieder erweitern
können und ja im Bundestrend
entsprechend vorangehen das vielleicht
von meiner Seite in aller Kürze genau
vielen Dank bitte
ja vielleicht Eingangs zu sagen als
Beginn was wir hier nach dieser Wahl
erlebt haben wir gesehen haben das
Rot-Rot-Grün klar abgewählt wurde denn
die Wähler haben hier eine klare
Positionierung gegeben für die
verheerende Politik der letzten Jahre
hier in Berlin möchte gleichwohl Herrn
Wegner zu seinem Wahlsieg gratulieren
aber auch unserer Spitzenkandidatin hier
in Berlin Christin Brinker mein
herzlichen Dank auch der gesamten
Bundespartei des gesamten
Bundesvorstandes ausdrücken für diesen
kurzen engagierten Wahlkampf genauso den
Wahlkämpfern auf der Straße den vielen
ehrenamtlichen Wahlkämpfern in unserer
Partei die bei Wind und Wetter und Frau
Brinker hat gesagt es war nämlich gerade
die besten Wettervoraussetzungen für
diesen Wahlkampf hier aber durch
durchaus ein sehr engagierten Wahlkampf
in Plakatierungen aber auch Info-Ständen
geleistet haben dafür noch mal recht
herzlichen Dank positiv noch dazu
erwähnen möchte ich dass wir auch hier
in Berlin unsere zweite direktwahlkreise
verteidigen konnten dass wir zwei
direkte Abgeordnete wieder ins
Abgeordnetenhaus in senden konnten dass
wir mit diesem Ergebnis mit diesem
Zuwachs zufrieden sind dass wir uns
konsolidiert haben gleichwohl auch
natürlich nach dem Bundestrend den wir
aktuell haben von 15 16 17 Prozent
einigen Umfragen uns ein zweistelliges
Ergebnis gewünscht hätten das muss man
ganz klar sagen in dieser Konstellation
nichtsdestotrotz ist die AFD gekommen um
zu bleiben das hat sich auch in diesem
Landesparlament bestätigt wir haben
wieder eine Landtagswahl mit zugewinnen
abgeschlossen positiv noch zu erwähnen
vielleicht abschließend ist dass der
Kriegskurs der kriegsfolie stracc
Zimmermann hier die FDP aus einem
weiteren Parlament gefegt hat das ist
mittlerweile das fünfte in dem die FDP
rausgeflogen ist also diese FDP braucht
in diesem Land niemand immer mehr Wähler
sehen lassen das ist positiv es gibt nur
eine wirklich wahrnehmbare Opposition im
nächsten im nächsten Stadtparlament das
wird die AFD sein wir werden natürlich
die CDU und das deutet sich ja in den
ersten Statements anderen Parteien an
wird hier wahrscheinlich an ihre eigenen
selbst ernannten Brandmauer scheitern
denn mit der CDU möchte ja
wahrscheinlich niemand koalieren so dass
Rot-Rot-Grün im ungünstigsten Fall hier
weiter regiert und die CDU mit ihrer
eigenen
brandmauer-scheitern wird und jetzt
selber sieht was eine Brandmauer
bedeutet vielen dank vielen Dank nun
haben Sie die Möglichkeit Ihre Fragen zu
stellen bitte
Herr Schindler
entscheidend
unterscheiden die Bundespolitik und die
Stadtpolitik hier in Berlin also die
Berliner das wird Frau Brinker
bestätigen haben aktuell sicherlich ganz
andere Probleme hier was die sozialen
Themen angehen was Wohnungsbau angeht
was Infrastruktur angeht was aber
natürlich auch die Preisentwicklung
angeht im übrigen sie haben es richtig
gesagt für 16 Prozent war das mit
wahlentscheiden für AFD Wähler das ist
aber schon ein dritter Position nach
Sicherheit in Ordnung und nach dieser
Inflation und Preissteigerung also es
war sehr wohl ein Thema aber natürlich
nicht das tragende Thema Nummer eins das
ist ganz klar das sind bundespolitische
Themen hier haben denke ich mal gerade
nach den Silvester allen ganz andere
Themen innenpolitischer Art und auch
sicherheitspolitische Art in eine große
Rolle gespielt und deswegen auch diese
wechselwille hier in Berlin möchten Sie
noch was hinzufügen Frauen
genau das ist der Punkt das war die
Erfahrung die wir auch im Wahlkampf
gemacht haben ja der Krieg in der
Ukraine beunruhigt viele Menschen und
gerade in Berlin wir sind ja hier erste
Anlaufstelle auch für ukrainische
Kriegsflüchtlinge gewesen und sind
während es auch in Zukunft sein das
bewegt die Menschen und viele gerade
auch im austeil der Stadt machen sich da
große Sorgen und wollen Frieden dass das
schon aber wir haben eben auch
festgestellt dass die Problemlage in
Berlin in der Hauptstadt so vielfältig
ist wo jeder auch individuell betroffen
ist sei es bei der Wohnungssuche sei es
ja mit dem ÖPNV nicht dahin zu kommen wo
man gerne hin möchte und so weiter das
hat tatsächlich äh viele Menschen dann
noch mehr bewegt abgesehen natürlich in
der Hauptsache auch von Silvester
globalen wie gehen wir mit der Polizei
um was macht das Thema innere Sicherheit
hier in Berlin und wie schlecht wird das
von
Rot-Grün-Rot tatsächlich auch bearbeitet
Frau Klasmann bitte gewesen
[Musik]
uktivpartei und der
angeboten haben
also jeden den sie in Berlin im
Abgeordnetenhaus und auch bei den WLAN
durchaus fragen und am Wahlkampfstand
der wird Ihnen sagen dass wir sehr wohl
sehr konstruktive Politik im
Abgeordnetenhaus machen das zeichnet
gerade unsere Fraktion auch aus und
insofern wir haben das Thema angestoßen
wir haben immer dieses Thema innere
Sicherheit als Hauptthema bearbeitet und
insofern haben wir ja auch zu Gewinne
und
Zuwächse erlebt dass die CDU jetzt diese
Gewinne hat ist interessant ist wichtig
ist vor allen Dingen für uns dass es der
Wähler dass der Wähler gezeigt hat er
möchte rot grün rot in dieser
Kombination offensichtlich nicht mehr
haben das ist eigentlich das
entscheidende also rot grün rot wird
nicht zugetraut wirklich die Probleme zu
lösen wenn man sich auch die
Einzelergebnisse in den Fußballkreisen
anschaut ist das ein ganz klares Zeichen
der Wähler
Herr Kirschner bitte
[Musik]
wir hatten vor anderthalb Jahren in der
Kombination Landtagswahl Bundestagswahl
ja die Situation dass sowas immer
grundsätzlich mehr Wähler an die
Wahlurnen zieht gemessen an den
vorherigen
einzelwahlen was das Abgeordnetenhaus
anbetrifft haben wir eine relativ gute
Wahlbeteiligung trotz allem gehabt und
man darf eins nicht vergessen viele
Berliner ja waren schon entsetzt über
das was hier im vor anderthalb Jahren
passiert ist viele Berliner haben auch
tatsächlich ja nicht mehr die Lust
gehabt zu wählen zu gehen weil sie
einfach auch Vertrauen schon verloren
haben in unsere Demokratie das wird
jetzt Aufgabe für die nächsten
dreieinhalb Jahre sein diese nicht
Wähler die sich aber Partei übergreifen
tatsächlich ähm darstellen die wieder an
die Wahl ohne zurückzuholen und ich bin
optimistisch dass uns das sind
dreieinhalb Jahren auf jeden Fall wieder
gelingen wird
gibt es weitere Fragen
Herr Steffen bitte
haben
nein das Thema ist überhaupt nicht
ausgereizt schon gar nicht in Berlin
weil die Probleme ja doch sehr
tiefgreifen sind also das was Silvester
passiert ist ist ja ein Problem was sich
über Jahre in dieser Stadt abbildet und
kulminiert ist letztlich auch in den
Silvester Krawallen wir erleben ja im
Moment auch folgendes oder wenn man auch
zurückschaut dass die CDU zwar dieses
Thema auch adressiert aber letztlich
wenn sie in Verantwortung ist ja
offensichtlich nicht
Problemlösungen geliefert hat und genau
das werden wir jetzt sehen je nachdem
wie die Regierung in Berlin ausschauen
wird die Koalition muss die CDU liefern
ob sie das wirklich tut das sage ich zu
bezweifeln und insofern mit uns hat der
Wähler klare Verhältnisse er weiß dass
wir bei dem Thema innere Sicherheit
immer eine klare Kante zeigen werden und
insofern mache ich mir da gar keine
Sorgen wie gesagt in dreieinhalb Jahren
werden wir schauen wie dann die
Stimmungslage ist und wer wirklich
geliefert hat vielleicht ergänzen dazu
Herr Steffen man muss natürlich auch
sagen wer auch mit verantwortlich ist
für diese Politik auch die
kriminalitäts die hier in Kriminalität
die hier in Berlin gerade stattfindet
das ist ja hauptsächlich mit die CDU das
müssen wir vielleicht ein Stück weit
immer wieder auch bemerkbar machen beim
Wähler denn es ist ja die um die Ursache
die hier auch in Berlin was Kriminalität
angeht hatte die CDU selbst geschaffen
und zwar auf Bundesebene mit ihrer
Migrationspolitik seit 2015 also hier
hat wirklich der brandstift da jetzt die
Feuerwehr gerufen und das erleben wir ja
überall und wenn wir jetzt mal sehen ob
die CDU auch wirklich hier ihren Wähler
Willen oder bzw der Wähler will ob der
überhaupt umgesetzt wird in Form von in
der Regierungsbildung da bin ich mal
gespannt also im Endeffekt kann es
durchaus sein dass die das gute Ergebnis
der CDU leider in Berlin niemand nutzt
das muss man einfach so deutlich sagen
weil die gleiche Politik weiter
betrieben wird und da muss man sich
schon überlegen und auch da sollte sich
auch die CDU überlegen in Zukunft wie
sie hier damit weiter umgeht
bin im Endeffekt sind dann wie es schon
eingangs gesagt habe die Brandmauern so
hoch dass man eigene mittlerweile
aufgebaut hat ohne dass die CDU
überhaupt hier gestalten kann und dass
der Wählerwille vor allem und das ist
das was ich nach dieser Wahl wirklich
ein Stück weit beschämend finde dass der
wählerwelle auch nicht mehr respektiert
oder akzeptiert wird
weitere Fragen bitte
also
wir haben uns natürlich mit
Verfassungsjuristen auch über diesen
eventuellfall unterhalten und wir gehen
im Moment nicht davon aus dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht diese
Wiederholungswahl für ungültig erklärt
weil der Schaden für die Demokratie dann
noch viel schlimmer wäre es war so schon
schlimm genug dass überhaupt so ein
wahlchaus überhaupt hier stattgefunden
hat in der Hauptstadt eines Industrie
Landes das muss man sich mal vorstellen
deswegen wie gesagt wir gehen nicht
davon aus dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in der
Hauptsache die Wahl für ungültig erklärt
wir gehen eher davon aus dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht Hinweise
liefern wird in der Hauptsache
Verhandlung wie im solch einem Falle
tatsächlich mit Wahl Wiederholungen im
Grundsatz umgegangen werden sollte dass
ist bisherige Maßgabe wir wie gesagt
sind absolut der Meinung dass das
Abgeordnetenhaus sich jetzt so wie es
gestern gewählt wurde auch
zusammensetzen wird und konstituieren
wird und die dreieinhalb Jahre
Legislatur noch entsprechend arbeiten
wird
keine weiteren Fragen doch Herr
Schindler bitte
angesprochen hat
79% der Berliner Wähler sagen dass ich
die AFD nicht genug von Rechtsextremen
Positionen distanziere sogar 37% der AFD
wieder sind diese Ansicht und ich würde
interessieren wie Sie diesen Befund
bewerten muss die AFD dann in dieser
Hinsicht mehr tun um da noch mehr weder
zu erreichen
wir erleben tatsächlich eine oder haben
erlebt eine gewisse Stigmatisierung
unserer Partei und ich sehe meine
Aufgabe vor allen Dingen auch in der
Zukunft darin diese Stigmatisierung
aufzulösen durch konstruktive Politik
genau in diesem Sinne wie ich das jetzt
schon die in den vergangenen Jahren hier
in Berliner Abgeordnetenhaus
vorgelebt habe und wie das auch meine
Fraktion
vorlebt und bearbeitet
insofern wie gesagt geben Sie mir noch
dreieinhalb Jahre und dann schauen wir
wie sich die Umfrageergebnisse dann
darstellen
ein Problem
noch mal wir sind eine Partei die
angetreten ist hier die Probleme in
Deutschland und in Berlin klar und
deutlich zu benennen das tun wir und
genau daran arbeiten wir auch und ähm ja
in unseren Kurs den wir hier in Berlin
fahren auch fortsetzen weil der aus
meiner Sicht und aus meiner persönlichen
Überzeugung auch erfolgreich sein wird
dazu muss man ja fragen rechtsextreme
Positionen da muss man die Gegenfrage
stellen welche Position meinen Sie denn
also unsere Position sind klar
beschlossen und das ist unser Partei und
unser Wahlprogramm und da kann ich keine
rechtsextremen Position sehen also von
daher ist es ein narrativ was man immer
wieder gerne bedient ich gebe ihnen aber
recht ja wir haben in der Vergangenheit
Fehler gemacht da haben wir auch
intensiv nach innen gearbeitet und auch
dort natürlich Konsequenzen gezogen aber
in der Weise wiederholen sich diese
Fehler nicht und von daher kann ich Frau
Brinker nur Recht geben auch da gibt es
eine Konsolidierung in unserer Partei
und wir schauen nach vorne und in die
Zukunft Frau Glas mal bitte
also bei uns im Landesverband oder der
Landesverband an sich das habe ich
gestern auch mit vielen Kollegen schon
besprochen steht dahinter mir der findet
auch diesen Kurs den wir hier in Berlin
eingeschlagen gut richtig und notwendig
wir sind eine Großstadt eine Großstadt
tickt grundsätzlich immer anders wie ein
Flächenland das muss man auch wissen und
entsprechend versuchen wir für die
Bürger Berlins hier die Politik zu
machen und da steht auch der
Landesverband absolut dahinter
Zusatz alles gesagt hinter mir ja hinter
mir als Person genau hervorrat bitte
unzufrieden
zu angepasst und man müsste dann so ein
bisschen schärfer sein dann würde dann
auf Ergebnisse
[Musik]
ganz genau sie haben das schon richtig
angesprochen Berlin ist ja eben eine
Großstadt mit ganz unterschiedlicher
Bewohner und wählerstruktur und es
überhaupt nicht zu vergleichen mit einem
Flächenbundesland und schon gar nicht zu
vergleichen mit den ostdeutschen
Bundesländern wir können sehr frohen
stolz sein dass unsere ostdeutschen
Bundesländer da oder die die
Landesverbände dort so gute Arbeit
leisten und die Menschen vor Ort dort
auch so gut überzeugen können aber sie
können sowas natürlich nicht eins zu
eins auf Berlin auf die Großstadt
übertragen auch wenn Sie sich zum
Beispiel Bremen oder Hamburg angucken
gibt es auch ganz andere
wählerstrukturen und Wähler Schichten
und auch andere Probleme die
angesprochen und adressiert werden
müssen das ist aber ein ganz klassisches
Phänomen was jetzt nicht zwingend was
mit uns als AFD zu tun hat wir werden
auf jeden Fall und das ist meine Maßgabe
ja versuchen unseren klaren Kurs weiter
hier in Berlin vorzuführen und auch und
das ist eben die große Herausforderung
tatsächlich sowohl den Ostteil der Stadt
auch als auch die wlanbestteil der Stadt
mitzunehmen zu erreichen und ich denke
das wird uns auch in Zukunft ganz gut
richtig gut sogar gelingen
ja vielleicht noch ergänzen dazu diese
regionalen Unterschiede auf die habe ich
ja schon immer auf Maxim gemacht die
sieben übrigen allen Parteien gibt also
es ist ja kein Phänomen der AFD das ist
nun äh unterschiedliche Bundesländer mit
unterschiedlichen Präferenzen für die
Parteien gibt also die gibt's natürlich
auch in Berlin den Kurs in Berlin und
auch für den Wahlkampf das ist immer
eine Angelegenheit des Landesverbandes
darauf verweise ich auch immer das muss
im Endeffekt der Landesverband die
Spitzenkandidatin und natürlich die
Mitglieder in Berlin selbst bestimmen
und am Ende auch selbst verantworten das
ist ganz klar wir unterstützen natürlich
als Bundesverband gern so haben wir es
auch getan und von daher ist der Kurs
wie gesagt wieder hier gefahren wird
nicht vergleichbar mit einem Kurs
eventuell in Sachsen oder Thüringen
wenngleich ich auch nicht immer große
Unterschiede da sehe also es wird immer
gerne hinein interpretiert als wenn dort
dann dort der Kurs vielleicht anders ist
also wie gesagt man muss hier die
soziale Komponente mit betrachten das
hat Frau Brinker ebenso richtig gesagt
auch zwischen Ost und West diese Teilung
gibt es zum Teil noch in Berlin
zumindestens was die afd-wählerschaft
angeht mittlerweile war konnte man noch
vor zehn Jahren doch den Querschnitt
machen also ich sag mal der Ostteil hat
er rot gewählt der Westteil dann doch
eher CDU und SPD also das ist
mittlerweile schon ein Stück weit
aufgebrochen also die sozialen Themen
sind in Berlin wichtig ich denke daran
sollte man auch hier in Berlin weiter
fortsetzen denn gerade in solchen
Wahlkreisen wie Marzahn haben soziale
Themen eine große Rolle gespielt und
wenn ich insgesamt natürlich auch sehr
wo wir gepunktet haben als Partei und
das ist das denn hier was wir auch in
Zukunft weiter und intensiver auch
ansprechen wollen das natürlich die
Arbeiter diejenigen die noch
wertschöpfen in diesem Land arbeiten und
auch die Angestellten also ein Stück
weit haben wir dort die die höchsten
Wähler zu wechseln bzw unser stammweller
Potenzial für die machen wir Politik die
sich in anderen Parteien mittlerweile
auch nicht mehr repräsentiert sehen
Herr Steffen bitte
[Musik]
getan
igungen
für russische Interessen wie gesagt
also da muss ich Ihnen ein bisschen
widersprechen wenn Sie unsere
Wahlumfragen auch im Westen sehen dann
können sie ja nicht sagen dass unser
Kurs im Westen schade das interpretieren
sie hinein der Wahlaufruf von Frau
Wagenknecht von Frau Schwarzer hat er
nichts mit einer Russland Nähe zu tun
auch das interpretieren sie hinein hier
geht's um einen Friedens an meinen
Friedens Resolution und auch einen
Petition die ich unterzeichnet habe und
die Inhalte die da drin vermerkt sind
die entstanden oder bzw kommen wir sogar
aus unserer eigenen Friedensresolution
die wir im Bundestag eingebracht haben
also sie ist eins zu eins übertragbar
interessant ist wie die Medien schade
natürlich dann aufschreckt insgesamt und
das finde ich ja das interessante auch
daran dass mittlerweile Schubladen die
man wo man auch gern Politiker und
Inhalte hineinstecken möchte dass sie
mittlerweile nicht mehr passen sie
fallen also überall hinaus und man kann
eben mittlerweile die Politiker nicht
mehr links rechts Mitte irgendwo
positionieren ich denke das ist auch
nicht nötig wenn es um Frieden geht und
das ist die Initiative die wir wie
gesagt als Bundestag Situation das
einzige Fraktion mit eingebracht haben
diese Woche es wissen sie und genauso
diese Petition von Frau wagenkneten Frau
Schwarzer ist man nie auf der falschen
Seite und deswegen habe ich das aus
Grund Überzeugung auch getan gibt es
weitere Fragen
da scheint nicht der Fall zu sein dann
vielen Dank für ihr Kommen Sie gut nach
Hause vielen dank vielen Dank